here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my channel
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
keep changing
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
didn't hear me
[Music]
look at me look at me
he looked at me
look at me you seem like a good man
you seem like a good man you're trying
to do your job because this woman's
mentally ill right you okay i'm great
great
is it hard putting in here is it
sure you're actually pretty quiet sure
yes because god is with me you have no
idea how much you've been abused look at
that noggin
bring me down no one will be who has
been abusing
everyone i've had no one
no one and god show me they thought i
would be greedy have you taken anything
today i did because god
uh i yeah
don't you feel a little sad none of this
is what god instructed god listen let's
do it let's do it
no oh sir don't you feel a little walk
where's the rest the cops where are they
god is great
don't you feel bad
the last one let me cook here an hour
you're gonna feel so bad oh my goodness
you really are you should let me out sir
because i can tell you care you're
struggling
you're struggling
you're struggling
i i i forgive you you said you're
actually a good cop
i wish you would have been one that
helped me but none of them did
god is great
god is great
oh i wish you let me have my whip i got
a little girl that went a couple of them
they danced around and act like they're
better than me god that's great i know
you ain't gonna take me to jail
i want you to take me to my house i want
to see the players
who who denied me deny gave him every
chance in the world
and i still love them
oh sir i know you're struggling you seem
like a really good man i'm sorry you had
to do that i know that was hard on you
and you didn't hurt me but i didn't
really feel it i didn't i didn't have
them come
let them
come let them come
let them come
oh please make her ask me
they got me
they correct me
oh
please
please
hey
hold on to that farmer
hold on
i'm gonna make it
under oh lord god come on we're gonna do
this
come on god bring it out of this car
when that man's gonna
he's going to regret it and we're gonna
love it
[Music]
restrain me
sir you don't want to do this you don't
i can tell you that god feared man
oh honey honey don't do it don't
you're a good man don't care i'm not
listen i only do it because
no one listens but i'll open it again
i'll open it again
oh
how long did i work
don't take my work yes
i want that
all right
give me more what no here we go again
oh lucky
look
here we go
[Music]
okay don't be around in front of
everybody it's gonna look bad for you oh
yes please the restraints 12 hours at
the hospital no one listened
no one looks like cried and begged for
every little thing
oh randall health dr singh and i
promised them all that i would win the
war
i want my wife i want my life
i've got some girls i've got to punish
take me to them take me to them i want
to see them like i want them to see me
like this please take me to my husband
take me to my beloved
here
i know you don't want to do this
i know you don't love me you want to do
this i do
i listen i will have done this
don't let god strike you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
follow up
[Music]
oh really
really boys
you don't know who you're dealing with i
really don't want to do this open the
door
i think it does you can open that door
sir
you're going to open up there
[Music]
you're gonna let me out of here
gonna let me out of here
you're going to let me out of here you
see that okay yeah you know you are
you i know you love god sir
uh-huh i know you will i know you will
oh where's everybody
they were so quick to take me away
before
why aren't you racing away
i want my wife
i want
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
oh my god
i'm a doctor
god they're not listening they're not
listening again
god you better make them listen
hey what's your name
what's your name
turn around come on i know you feel bad
sir
sir
turn around i forgive you i forget god
loves you
god loves you i know you're torn
come on over here it's okay let me out
sir
sir
come on god loves you
you're struggling
okay sir
turn around
turn around
you will pick up the weapon under to me
and open the door
sir
[Music]
i know you hear me come on you're such a
good i feel bad for you i can tell your
struggle you really didn't want to hurt
but you did
but i really didn't feel it i don't feel
anything i've been hurt and beat my
whole life pick up the weapon bring it
to me i've got some people to punish
they punish me hard and i really don't
want to do it but
a lesson must be learned
please pick up the whip and bring it to
me
sir
sir come i know you hear me sir i'm not
gonna yell anymore
[Music]
bring it to me i'm not i'm gonna just
wave it around some girls who's that
they were better than me what's going on
with that picture oh cause that look
that's for a little camera little time
romance with the wrong husband it's my
beloved husband and she's the weight oh
oh sir bring me the whip i'm not going
to even touch them i'm just going to
wipe it around and shave them
come on pick up the whip and let's go
it's just you and me come on you're
gonna drive me away and take me to them
pick up the web
check out the web
there's all the work and i need that
pitchfork too
i did it come on
come on
anymore come on you're a good man i can
tell you're really struggling to come on
i know you believe in jesus and god
pick up the whip and the pitchfork and
get in the god no one will stop you i
promise
god has you son
god has you and you are really
struggling i can tell pick up the weapon
bring me the pitchfork
pick up the whip and bring me the bitch
funk
pick up the whip and bring me the bitch
folk come on
pick up the whip and bring me the
pitchfork
and drive away come on no one will stop
you i promise you will walk with me
righteous pick up the weapon the
pitchfork sir and get in the car
yes
i know you will you can now you're not
going to talk anymore i know you're not
who is that
pitchfork
who walks down my face
so i know you didn't really want to do
this why are you taking them off because
you know you're
look what they did to me
[Music]
uh
gently put okay in or no we're rocking
me
no i didn't never have enough for that
okay i need something
how can i get you something oh i really
need something
you know i mean really
listen guys
you're pretty good you can't have water
and you don't believe in god
tell the people the truth the believers
the pastors the the ones who think they
are my husband who belittles me
without my face
i need that pitchfork yes with the
restraints i wanted to see you in full
regalia i do he really killed me and
said i i i didn't punish i wasn't
punished enough
i wanted to sleep yes please i wanted
this thing okay no no no i really need
that water don't forget the pitchfork
you're super thirsty yeah
yeah don't forget the pitchfork
and i need my yogi and don't forget that
bitch i need that what
i need that whip
i'm not going to touch him i'm going to
wave around those little girls got a
lesson
they're going straight to hell don't
forget it
don't forget it
yeah
i
i know you're going to get it
get it
go over and get it
go over and get it
go over and get it
go over and get it
god wants you to pick it up son
i really need that water and it's right
there
it's right who is going to give me the
water
who
who
don't forget the pitchfork
i need that width
yeah
we're not leaving without it i'm done to
go
oh here we go here we go
here we go
hey
hey
hi
i know you hear me sir
you hear me
i need you to pick up the pitchfork i
need to fit fork and
the width
i need a pitchfork and the wet
i need that pitchfork in the web so do
you remember what you did say i uh i
don't even care god instructed me to
it's what the task sir
don't you leave that whip we need it
sir
somebody going to bring it they aren't
they
yeah i know they are it's okay let's
talk you know what they did
they really
i'm great never been better it's in my
house i want to see the players
who denied me
deny gave him every chance in the world
and i still love them
oh sir i know you're struggling you seem
like a really good man i'm sorry you had
to do that i know that was hard on you
and you didn't hurt me but i didn't
really feel it i didn't
have them come
come
let them come
let them come
oh please figure out me
take
me
correct me
oh
please
please
hey
hold on the little boy
hold on
i'm gonna
lord god come on we're gonna do this
come on guys bring it out of this car
when that man's gonna
he's going to regret it
and we're gonna
love it
[Music]
yes